hey Ron morning Leslie do you have a
good night
I did I watched a really good document
what is that this is what I did last
night
after I got home I drank six more
glasses of whiskey and then I finished
crafting this small harp using a bandsaw
a spokeshave and an oscillating spindle
sander
[Music]
beautiful but wait there's more here are
some photographs of me drinking the
whiskey you'll notice I'm holding up
yesterday's newspaper so you can tell
that I'm not lying I feel like I'm in a
spa lemonade please and thank you hey
I'm sorry if I was Curt earlier I'm a
single mom and sometimes things get
chaotic around here when you shut up
from the parts typologies I understand
completely this is delicious
I got it from food and stuff so that's
where we got these gloves right so how
exactly are you gonna fix this hole just
for my own edification I dug the loose
gravel out of the hole now I'm using a
jackhammer to remove the larger pieces
then I'll spray down the hole to settle
the dust and fill it with cold patch
asphalt well thank you now I can fix the
next one myself mark Brendan danowitz
hey Ron what's up I have a wood shop and
I'm planning a little expansion need my
buddy mark the city planner to sign off
on the plans sure I just gave the
schedule an inspection that's not really
necessary yes it is but you'll be fine
as long as you don't have any code
violations
you don't have any code violations deal
No
Andrew are you aware that your bathroom
faucet is leaking are you kidding me
I just stuffed a saucony yesterday what
else do they want me to do there's an
exposed wire above the bathtub as well
oh yeah shock wire I call it that
because if you take a shower and you
touch the wire you die yes that is
accurate do you have a toolbox yeah
no home is complete without a proper
toolbox
here's April and Andy's a hammer half of
a pretzel baseball card some cartridge
that says Sonic and Hedgehog a scissor
half and a flashlight filled with
jellybeans
Ron what was wrong with that one it was
too perfect
it looked a machine made
and the time I've worked here I've taken
great pains to see as little of this
building as possible
turns out the third floor is silent
empty and completely free of government
work I can't think of anything more
beautiful to share with my son if I had
a toolbox I could take care of that
faulty radiator this place is a paradise
hey Mark welcome to my Haven thank you
you were the first non me to set foot in
this building in ten years none of this
is up to code sure it is it's up to the
Swanson code there's no drainage doesn't
seem to be any ventilation
you've got Hauser's chemicals over here
yeah which only I'm breathing the same
liberty that gives me the right to fart
in my own car are you gonna tell a man
that he can't fart in his own car there
is a basket of oil soaked rags above a
wood-burning stove
good thing I've got a fire extinguisher
which I can assure you it's totally up
to your precious code this says it
should be recharged June of 1996 those
dates are arbitrary they're like those
expiration dates that the government
forces companies to put on yogurt
medicine observe watch yourself yeah
okay I'll replace this happy my fav new
item is a deliciously bold chair my
local artist Ron Swanson Ron Swanson is
here he will be joining us after the
break so stick around that woman call my
chair delicious I guess we could go to a
pharmacy but I really don't want to use
like a cheap plastic ring I'd hate to
say this but Ann Perkins has terrible
taste in rings what is this it's a toe
ring with a brown gemstone is this a
ruby that's gone bad I am out of ideas
jewelry store
no that's close that's why we're doing
this perhaps I can be of service how how
much you think Ann would miss the sconce
I don't know it's part of her house
yeah well okay it's not rocket science
I removed the sconce fired up my
grandfather's torch heated up the pieces
in a cast-iron bucket liquefied the
metal poured into a mold
obviously keep it over a low flame to
achieve a nice temper cool didn't
antifreeze and just forged and shaped
the Rings any [ __ ] with a crucible and
acetylene torch and a cast-iron waffle
maker could have done the same whole
thing only took me about 20 minutes
people who buy things are suckers 5 26
27 28 violations come on
brendanawicz relax let me make you a
canoe uh well I don't need a canoe Ron I
need you to fix this place up so I'll
give you 24 hours
[Music]
hi there is there a project you're
working on I know more than you all
right when April and Andy married I
didn't get him a wedding present in my
experience wedding presents are nothing
more than kindling on the divorce
bonfire but I think I found a way I can
really help them make a home just as we
suspected John we repaired the valve
stem seal and now all that remains is to
tighten down this packing nut and that
should do it can we help you no we have
everything under control
my crews redoing this whole floor were
the only people allowed up here right
now well proceed with your work you
won't notice us at all well we're gonna
be kind of loud my son is several weeks
old
he's quite familiar with the sound of
power tools oh my goodness we are back
with America's greatest leader Annabel
Porter and her new favorite artisan
local woodworker Ron Swanson hello
I discovered Ron's chairs a few months
ago and what I absolutely love about a
Swanson is you can really use it for
anything yes mostly you use it for a
sitter make it a rustic accent piece in
your solarium even better use it as a
focal point in your yoga tent put it by
a table and eat a meal we don't do meals
in my home no every two hours we eat
what I like to call a food tease like an
oat wedge or a seaweed lozenge
[Music]
are you doing here the most important
government work I've ever done sanding
rat urine stains out of this floor there
he is
hello hello thank you for your kind
words about my chairs mr. Porter no
thank us you are about to make a ton of
money
I want to license your designs we are
gonna put Swanson chairs in every six
bedroom home in the Midwest if my chairs
were mass-produced that wouldn't be
Swanson chairs Swanson chairs are
handmade yes and now that will be made
by a thousands of tiny Chinese hands
there I think I got it you got it oh do
you at least tell me what you're doing
I'm a homeowner right would like to
actually learn something yeah I'm
tightening the valve stem into the valve
shank I'm replacing the handle and then
tightening the set screw to hold it in
place no oh my god that's a good feeling
sense of accomplishment pride damn it I
just love it so much
are you okay great I'm gonna go around
this house and fix everything I can find
that needs fixing you want to help I
really do good this next look John it's
red pine they were gonna put flecked
linoleum over this beautifully preserved
knotty red pine most people in this
world John are asked this is the best
day I've ever spent in a government
building and luckily my son was here to
share it with me
he now has that satisfied look that only
comes with the pride of Labor or he
pooped either way well done John
you